Jaakko yes in the SEAL Teams you led all
male teams any leadership difference in
business were in the business world with
mixed gender or female teams so first of
all in the military I did work with
women there's no women in SEAL Teams but
there's women that are Intel there's
women that are in logistics there's
women in them in some of the logistics
support units that go out in the field
sometimes so definitely worked with
women in the military and in the
civilian sector with with echelon front
I work with all kinds of women all kinds
of women in every level from CEOs on
down to frontline troopers and here's
the deal for me it's no factor no factor
to me
what's a factor to me is can they do
their job
do they have an open mind are they
humble do they treat people with respect
those are the kind of things that I'm
judging it's like what we talked about
earlier I'm judging but I'm not judging
based on what they are I'm judging on
who they are and who they are as a
person so that's yeah I I see no real
difference the leadership the way that
you lead doesn't change in my opinion
from though from the women I've seen in
leadership positions to the men I've
seen in leadership positions the the the
way they lead is successful because the
way they lead not because they're male
or female and you know some of the
stereotypes that that you might see out
there like he like like for instance men
are tougher than women or men or women
are more emotional than men that's just
garbage and if you see I've seen at
least when you get to a leadership
position I've definitely seen women that
were way tougher than guys were in terms
of hey we got to make this move for the
company here's what I'm gonna do boom
they execute it and I've seen men that
were way too emotional and touched to
this scenario and ruin it because
they're just the way more emotional than
the stereotypical woman might be so
that's why I just don't think you can
trust um I look at a person I weathered
a man or woman I'm looking at their the
content of their character for
the second time I'll say that today I'm
okay and now when we start talking about
combat there's some physical differences
that make that make a definite impact
and I talked about on Tim Kennedy if you
want to hear me talk about that because
yeah when you get into some physical
things men are stronger than women and
so there's a there's some physical
limitations there but in terms of
leadership capabilities in this in the
civilian sector there's yeah I'm not I'm
not I'm not worried about men and women
do you okay are there some nuances there
there are there are newest for instance
to like one you'll hear is um I'll get
asked you know I'm a female and I'm in
charge of these guys you know how should
I act or what should I do
well because they they might not like
working for a furrow for a girl and I
say well they fired that back I probably
like working for a guy either or a free
younger guy or for a guy that got moved
from another department there's it's the
same thing it's the same thing so what
are you gonna do it's the same thing
always say be humble listen to what they
have to say keep an open mind that's
what you're gonna do regardless male
female whatever it just yeah older
younger doesn't matter you want it the
being a good leader the principles don't
change that's all there is to it yeah
yeah because as an insecure guy getting
getting led or or a girl calling shots
or whatever will affect them mm-hmm but
like I said if they if their leadership
principles are sound yeah
doesn't matter making the right call
it's gonna be obvious and that like that
guy's messing up or you know like he's
he's acting out of insecurity or not
acting out of insecurity it's gonna be
obvious the leadership part as long as
that sound you're gonna have success
yeah yeah so yeah one that's no factor
to me
next question there maybe I should bring
some of the female leaders that I've
worked with on the podcast you know the
thing the problem with that is they're
no different than the male leaders of
work works I'm sure that there's some
some women to listen this nickel oh you
don't know how hard it is when X mm-hmm
well you don't know I but that's what
I'm saying like though good female
leaders I've worked with have been like
oh yeah that can be sometimes a problem
cuz I'm a woman and here's what I do to
negate it
because guess what the next day I'll be
working with a different client and the
it's a man and he goes well you know I
have to deal with X and this is how I
medicate ik so everyone's dealing with X
everyone's got some factor that they're
trying to overcome and it's just a good
leader will find a way around that
factor or find a way to mitigate that
factor and a bad leader won't and will
then use that factor as an excuse rather
than just as an advantage you know
there's a huge difference between taking
ownership of these problems and saying
oh you know what here's the issue
okay I'm gonna own that I'm gonna take
care of it I'm gonna find a way around
it instead of saying oh I'm younger I'm
older I'm a woman I'm a man trying to
lead these boys it's like no you're a
human leading another human being and so
step up and lead figure out what the
issues are and overcome them